another thing dr bright is not allowed  to do at the foundation dr bryant is not  allowed to classify any researcher  including himself as a memetic hazard  memetic hazards are not to be taken  lightly many of the scp foundation's  best and brightest have been cut down in  their prime by mimetic hazards that ate  away at their sanity and destroyed their  minds just because dr bright likes  singing the song that never ends and  annoying everyone that does not make him  a mimetic hazard by foundation standards  other behaviors that do not qualify a  researcher as a memetic hazard include  but are not limited to whistling all the  time clipping their nails at their desk  or microwaving fish in the break room